this episode was made possible by Wix
build your own professional website with
Wix by following the link below if you
are interested in space exploration
you've probably had a conversation with
someone who thinks it's a waste of time
and money why would we go to space when
we can't even take care of our current
home why should we spend money to visit
other planets when there are starving
children around the world to be fair
these are reasonable questions in this
episode we're going to address those
concerns and discuss whether space
exploration is a productive way to spend
our valuable resources let's start with
the idea that money spent on space
missions is money down the drain NASA's
budget for the past several years has
hovered around half a percent of the
total u.s. discretionary budget a little
under 21 billion dollars sounds like a
lot of money we could spend that money
to build shelters or schools or
something right
sure but let's look at some other areas
of spending that might also contribute
consumers spent 20 2.8 billion dollars
on McDonald's last year over two billion
dollars more than NASA gets in 2017 in
the US alone people spent a hundred and
twenty billion dollars on tobacco mainly
cigarettes that's six times NASA's
annual budget now if we compare these
three areas of spending which do you
think contributes more to society what
does are spending on McDonald's give us
a quick lunch and insane rates of
obesity
what about tobacco just cancer really
what about space missions nothing much
just weather satellites GPS LED lighting
water purification systems home
insulation wireless headsets
freeze-dried food the modern smoke
detector of the computer mouse and
countless other incredibly useful tools
and facets of modern society that we
take for granted today every year NASA
releases a publication called spin-off
which catalogues civilian uses of
technology developed by NASA or in
partnership with them the list is
extensive and includes a number of
technologies that greatly reduce the
amount of suffering in places like
Africa where clean water is hard to come
by so the next time someone claims that
we're wasting money that could be spent
on improving lives here on earth remind
them of all the tools that have been
developed as a direct result of the
space industry even based on this one
point space exploration is objectively
not a waste of money because it
contributes so much more useful
technology than many other industries as
with a lot of things people have this
noble misguided idea that we could
reallocate money from some source of
spending to help solve problems
the world for example they'll say things
like we could dig a thousand wells with
that amount of money the idea is nice
but it's naive do you really think if we
didn't allocate half a percent of the
budget to space research it would be
spent on humanitarian endeavors instead
of course not
it would likely be tossed into the
enormous defense budget to be spent on
fighter jets or Tomahawk missiles this
is like when you didn't finish your
dinner as a kid and your mother would
say there are starving kids who would
love to eat that well yeah that's true
but what exactly am I supposed to do
about it I can't exactly mail them my
leftover broccoli with space spending
it's an even more ridiculous claim
because the technology we developed for
space missions is directly and
measurably benefiting at-risk and
struggling populations around the world
so really not spending the money on the
space industry would be decidedly worse
than spending it and letting the
technology find civilian uses another
big complaint some critics have is that
we treat the earth so poorly and we've
done so much damage already that it
should be our number-one priority we can
all agree on this point we have been
poor stewards of our home planet we have
floating islands of trash in the oceans
we are speeding up climate change at an
alarming rate thanks to fossil fuel use
and industrial animal farming
we're already experiencing the
consequences of erratically damaged
global climate and we think we'd do it
better elsewhere in the universe it's a
fair point
but only on the surface yes our greed
and consumerism has done likely
irreparable harm to the earth but you
know how we can help by switching to
renewable energy sources like solar and
you know where we figure out the best
ways to manufacture and implement super
efficient solar technology the freezing
vacuum of space thanks to the space
industry we're able to utilize and
benefit from incredibly efficient solar
arrays here on earth helping reduce the
need for energy from fossil fuels in the
future we could slowly move our
manufacturing off the earth and into
space to further reduce our
environmental impact on a slightly
unrelated note if someone says space
exploration is a waste of money because
we're destroying the earth remind them
to vote for representatives that have a
strong green energy platform if we elect
politicians that respect the earth the
situation will gradually improve and
we'll see more renewable energy
replacing fossil fuels and we'll leave
the earth a greener place for future
generations which will allow them the
luxury of really applying their minds to
more advanced challenges of space
exploration another response to the idea
that leaving the earth is a waste of
money is that as far as we know we're
the only sentient life in the entire
universe if someday a massive planet
killing asteroid comes our way that's it
our species as well as every other
species on earth is done for what
greater cause could we find than the
continuation of our species I guess you
could say if everyone is dead then no
one is suffering but that doesn't really
count by spending the money on space
missions today we're building the
groundwork for future generations to
establish colonies elsewhere in the
solar system giving humanity a backup in
case the earth gets obliterated in a
freak natural disaster or nuclear war
and finally possibly the most honest
answer to the question of why bother
leaving the earth is just because that's
what we do humans have always explored
what's over that mountain what's across
this ocean we overcome obstacles not
because we have to but because we want
to we have this innate drive to learn to
explore to become the best version of
ourselves and space exploration is the
natural extension of our story and
history of adventure and knowing the
unknown so the next time you have a
discussion with someone who thinks that
space exploration is pointless you have
some answers the technology we developed
for space missions has innumerable uses
here on earth including green energy and
humanitarian tools we spend a fraction
of a percent of the annual budget on
NASA and get so much more out of it than
from other vastly more expensive
industries we're paving the way to help
ensure the survival of humanity both on
earth and among the stars and it's part
of our nature to boldly go where no one
has gone before those sound like pretty
good reasons to me going to space is
difficult you know it's not difficult
building a professional website with Wix
with Wix you can build amazing
professional websites for just about any
applications Wix can handle any project
you throw at it
whether you want to host videos share
your photo gallery but clients sell
products or just about anything else you
could ever want
whether you need a professional website
for your own personal use or for
e-commerce music hotels or restaurants
Wix does all the heavy lifting like
hosting custom domains email marketing
and more allowing you to focus on the
creative side of things you have total
creative freedom over your websites
allowing for limitless possibilities and
you don't even have to be a web designer
Wix caters to everyone regardless of
skill level whether you're a novice
business owner or a seasoned website
builder so if you want to build your
very own professional website visit Wix
by following the link below